I mean certainly the moral progress that
is required to say the world can take
place in a context devoid of religion I
mean the kind of enlightenment that that
it takes for people to accept one
another is not something that has to
take place in the context of religion on
the other hand I don't I certainly don't
think that that progress even the kind
of ultimate progress that that's
necessary requires shedding religion per
se it may require abandoning some
beliefs that are that are characteristic
of religion in some places or in some
brains right now it certainly does but
you know if you you can certainly be I
think in an abundantly moral humane and
enlightened person and be religious in a
meaningful sense the now certain there
are certain doctrines that there may be
important religious doctrine there are
religious doctrines that are important
to some people that will probably have
to be shed yes for them for the good of
the world certainly the idea that you
know not only is my god kind of better
than yours but so long as you believe in
the wrong God you know we can't do
business or I should kill you or
something but almost nobody actually
believes that in any of these religions
if you look at the way people actually
live they're much more practical than
that and and so I wouldn't say that
they're any mainstream beliefs that have
to be abandoned and we don't we don't
have to have like a single religion that
all that's really required is tolerance
of other of other beliefs and and in
that sense maybe a certain amount of
intellectual humility but I don't think
you need some sort of merger of
religious beliefs
there are doctrines that could help like
the notion of the Godhead
the idea that the different gods that
are worshipped may be made all just
different manifestations of a single
underlying divine unity that might be a
productive thing for people to agree on
but even that I wouldn't say is
essential